puis il ya l'amour vous avez beaucoup
proposé depuis le début c'est comparer
le verbe comparez vous êtes donc ce
qu'on appelle un comparatif si on
voulait me définir je suis de comparatif
vous êtes comparatisme mais je suppose
que à la rubrique profession sur votre
passeport vous n'avez pas mis
comparatiste parce que les douaniers
comprendrait rien à vous mettez
professeur honoraire 4 malgré tout match
de votre vie vous avez été professeur
aux études et au collège de france
jeunes aux études en 38 à tout moment
vous avez un peu avant trente cinq 35
donc alors que n'avions pas une géniale
intuition
oui j'adorerais mais des hommes ont fait
français et nous retrouvons jahic
respect et puis le collège de france
elles connaissent de france ça c'est
après la guerre canadiens qui ont 48
heures en bus sans doute
dix ans après le petit à petit intuition
quelque chose de professeurs étiez vous
un professeur mandarin n'auront charge
j'avais fait trop d'erreurs dans ma
jeunesse pour eux mandarine et non et
encore aujourd'hui quand je m'aime bien
me soumettre des idées qui me paraît
saugrenue jamais je ne le décourage
aller au bout de votre pensée ou
herbiers vous ça vous même s'il fait
impasse jésus bienvenus je n'ai jamais
de ma vie diriger une thèse
jamais de ma vie je n'ai donné un sujet
de diplômes au collège de france on n'y
a pas d'examen n'y a pas le nom mais à
l'école des hautes études on peut faire
un diplôme
jamais je mets proposés un sujet de
diplômes d'étudiants qu'il me proposait
faire avec untel ou untel j'aurais
horaires de diriger d'agir sur la france
y est quelqu'un mais j'ai vu par ci par
là que vous avez suscité des oppositions
violentes soit de m
ce n'est pas fini et c'est pas fini
non ce soit l'historien des religions
soit de latinos tellement d'histoires
dire des ruptures mais des spécialistes
les par exemple prenez les choses
romaine où quelqu'un qui n'a fait que de
la littérature de l'histoire romaine de
l'or que le giro mène ce fait d origine
roumaine une certaine idée à partir des
éléments qu'il a alors l'idée que l'inde
ou l'irlande puisse apporter un élément
d'explication les origines de rome à
chaud et pas du tout par paresse
l'esprit mais ils sont tellement bien
installé dans leur cocon n'est ce pas
que tous les rayons extérieur leur font
mal et c'est la même chose pour la
plupart pendant longtemps les indiennes
j'aime pas une opposition chez les
indiens ni on a eu après il ya déjà eu
bien sûr mais je comprends ce qu'il ya
des rites ans pourquoi vous irriter
certains professeurs parce que vous êtes
un touche à tout vous allez vous passer
de l'irlande à l'inde en passant par
hogg c'est la comparaison est oui mais
vous déranger des certitudes
c'est normal